okay let's go for a three minute game
uh this is fm dr people
from france and i do get another white
here um
and the three minute game means that i
will be able to talk
a little bit less i think so i'm going
for the
main line of the of the petrov here
um let's see what he what he has in in
store
i'm sure he um
he's well he's well versed in in theory
here
rook e8 yeah some very reasonable move
usually um usually here you go for a
quick
quick attack of some sort so i think
this is
very reasonable um
i could go knight e5 but i wanna i
wouldn't try an attack
now knight d3 is logical but i would go
queen d3
and uh yeah again i just want to attack
so i'm giving up i'm giving up this
piece and hoping for
some some serious
attacking chances also i could have gone
bishop 87 immediately
here i think would also have been
interesting
knight g4 seems seems uh like the most
logical move here
probably go rook d to e1 then to keep
the tension
um yeah f5
guess this is also also reasonable
but i'm just gonna try and blow
everything open
takes the knights i open the h file of
course
and queen a5
bishop d4 looks very good now queen h3
followed by queen h7 is a threat
also just opening the
um the um
third rank for the queen i think is in
general
very useful for me i think rosa rook h8
um queen uh sorry king h8 queen h3
king j8 g6 maybe a decisive threat
basic conclusion is is he's in a lot of
trouble here c5 would lose to
um it would lose to queen
[Music]
queen c4 and may to follow shortly there
because he cannot block
on the diagonal
queen a2 if g6
there is there is fg4 and there's no
longer
queen um queen h7 so i need to think
here a little bit
queen in a2 also helps
with the defense because later on the
queen can come to g8 let's say after
rook h8
queen h3 and then g6 um
maybe there is some defense there based
on
but then again i i don't i don't see it
concretely so i think i'm just going to
go for rocket j8
in that line king f8 would still be mate
after queen h8
um queen h8 and then um
uh bishop g7 so
some sort of defense would have to be
based on bishop f6 i think
and then bishop f6 king f8
but it looks it looks hard to hard to
believe
actually i i think i had a very nice
line there just to pause the second
bishop f6 bishop takes f6
uh king f8 yeah there's bishop g7
there's teeny 7 maybe
so maybe that wasn't but now
we do do probably get the chance to
deliver a nice mate
um again queen h8
uh sorry queen h7 is a is a massive
threat um and king f8 now there is
bishop takes g7
kings hg7 since there's no king e7
and then queen h7 king f6 g5 king e6
queen f7 would have been made
rookie 2 is a nice attempt at counter
play
because it threatens queen a a1 mate
but unfortunately for him i get to get
to deliver another checkmate and now
um now there's now there's a background
checkmate instead
uh okay i think that was that was pretty
uh pretty cool
uh regardless of the like objective
evaluation of that uh that was
um that was a good one